okay so the topic of today's video is
going to be the ozone layer and it's
depletion so let's go ahead and get
started so what is the ozone layer well
it's the portion of Earth's atmosphere
that absorbs the UV radiation from the
Sun like you see in the animation the
ozone layer kinda acts like a shield
that surrounds the earth and tries to
prevent the incoming UV rays from
striking the surface of the earth now as
wonderful as the ozone layer is it's not
a hundred percent effective some UV
radiation does strike the surface of the
earth but it does a really good job in
protecting the earth from incoming UV
radiation and so the ozone layer is
located in the port in the lower portion
of the Earth's stratosphere which is one
of the layers of the atmosphere well
let's go and see how a zone is formed so
then how is ozone formed well it all
starts when an incoming photon of UV of
UV light strikes a molecule of oxygen o2
the oxygen that we breathe the UV the UV
light will cause this oxygen molecule to
split into individual oxygen atoms
well ozone which is oh three forms when
one of those oxygen atoms bonds with
another Oh two in the atmosphere you
know one plus two equals three and so if
you missed it here comes another
incoming photon of UV light which
strikes an o2 molecule that causes the
o2 molecule be broken apart for me oh
three and one more time if you missed it
incoming UV breaks apart in Oh two
forming oh three so this has been al
happening for millions and millions and
millions of years in our atmosphere and
so the the ozone ozone layer absorbs UV
radiation but you know it's not really
just an ozone layer there's more than
just a zone yes there is oh three in the
ozone layer oh three is ozone there's
also two which is the oxygen that we
breathe
Oh two and there's also just regular
single oxygen
and so here comes a UV photon that
strikes an O three molecule o three
again is ozone so what happens is the UV
light is going to cause that o three to
be broken apart that's okay because
notice what happened that single oxygen
atom bonded with an O two to recreate a
molecule of ozone if you missed it here
it is again UV will break apart and O
three that's okay
because a new oh three is formed and if
you missed it UV breaks apart in O three
that's okay
another oh three is formed and one more
time
UV breaks apart an O three ozone
molecule only to form another one so the
ozone layer are the ozone and ozone
molecules in the ozone layer are
wonderful at blocking out certain types
of UV radiation particularly UVB and UVC
radiation but also there's also two O
two in the ozone layer
Oh two actually does a pretty good job
of blocking out other forms of UV
radiation as well
when UV strikes an O two that will it'll
break apart the O two to form ozone
notice how a UV is striking an O two
breaks apart the O 2 forming ozone but
notice how in the animation so far none
of the UV s have actually reached the
surface of the earth
now as wonderful as this shield is you
know the ozone shield is not a hundred
percent effective some UV light will
ultimately reach the surface of the
earth and we'll talk about those
negative side effects in a moment so
when we look at how the we look at the
state of the ozone layer today we need
to discuss
chlorofluorocarbons these are man-made
molecules common to aerosols
refrigerator and air-conditioning
clearance and phone production so here's
a molecule of CFCs chlorofluorocarbons
and what happens is UV UV radiation UV n
we'll break apart the chlorine from the
rest of the CFC melt like units really
the chlorine that does the damage the
chlorine will then attach itself to an O
3 ozone molecule and break away one of
the oxygen atoms it's not ozone anymore
it's just had an oxygen removed but
chlorines not quite done that chlorine
can be freed when its oxygen atom bonds
with another oxygen atom and that will
free up the chlorine in order to repeat
this process the freed up chlorine can
then rip away an oxygen from another oh
three and once the chlorine is freed
again it can repeat the process and
break away another break apart another
ozone molecule so in this animation I
had one chlorine destroying three ozone
molecules while in reality clone is a
very sturdy very long lasting atom up
here and can actually last for decades
destroying tens and hundreds of
thousands of ozone molecules so we saw
this earlier you know what is the ozone
layer at this point I hope you
understand that it's a shield that
surrounds the earth and and blocks
incoming UV radiation so then what is
ozone layer depletion well it's the
thinning of the ozone layer if you look
in the animation notice how the ozone
layer has been thinned due to the use of
chlorofluorocarbons CFCs and as you see
in the animation this is causing more
and more UV radiation to strike the
surface of the earth and so these are
some of the negative side effects of
that UV exposure causes skin cancers eye
cataracts it impairs and weakens our
immune system it stunts and harms the
growth of crops kills phytoplankton
which is the basis of marine and ocean
ecosystems so these are some of the side
effects of of decades and decades of use
of chlorofluorocarbons
so I'd like to finish with an awareness
timeline that kind of brings us to where
we are today in 1974 a couple scientists
discovered that chlorofluorocarbons
particularly the chlorine from a CFC
can break down ozone and this kind of
set us down a path to trying to find a
resolution to this problem in 1978 the
United States banned the use of CFCs in
aerosol cans that ban is still in you
existence today in 1984 over Antarctica
a seasonal hole in the ozone layer was
discovered and then in 1987 an
international agreement known as the
Montreal Protocol agreed to phase down
the use of CFCs and you can see in the
graph the amount of CFCs Rises until you
get to the 1990s and then they start to
flatten out and even start to decrease
and this is I want to end with a very
positive note that the outlook for for
ozone depletion is quite promising it's
predicted that in the next 50 60 years
possibly by 2050 2060 in that timeframe
we're going to see a return to the 1980
levels of ozone in the atmosphere so
this is one of those cases where you
know when the world agrees to solve a
problem you know we can see some
positive effects so that's it for this
video go ahead and post your thoughts
below and if you have any questions
perhaps I can try to respond to them
thank you for watching